welcome back to new rockstars i'm tommy
bechtolde the 1978
star wars holiday special is so bizarre
it haunts our yuletide
sugar plum visions it's even inspired a
new guardians of the galaxy holiday
special debuting this thing is so weird
we had to give it a bootleg breakdown
what the [ __ ] is the bootleg breakdown
you asked well why didn't you pay
attention
last time bootleg breakdowns are where i
dive into the scummy ponds of the
cheesiest crumbiest campiest specials in
movies that are just so
bad they make eric boss go tommy please
stop calling me this late just go do it
yourself
well thanks eric now that uncle tommy
has the wheel i'm going to guide you
through the unintentionally hilarious
moments that happened throughout this
star
wars story in this case wtf stands for
what
the force these aren't criticisms these
are celebrations of the reasons we
should
all know and love this story no matter
how ridiculous it is
so don't have a bad feeling about this
the star wars holiday special debuted in
1978 just
one year after the first star wars movie
a new hope fans looking for an extension
of the lore and story of the first star
wars film were instead
treated to a 90-minute fever dream that
seems less about star wars
and more about star wars with the dollar
signs instead of asses get it
like sweet sweet cash baby moolah
credits
books in this breakdown i'm going to
explain how this special served as a
baby step
in star wars journey from film and saga
into
brand and franchise merchandise
talking about you people who bought the
jar jar binks watches i'm one of those
people the first wtf moment is
literally the first moment of the whole
special from the cold open with han and
chewie that establishes
chewbacca has a family to the opening
credits that just feel so
not star wars-y musical guest
max rebo we even get teased the robert
smigiel-esque cartoon
why isn't there just a crawl isn't that
what star wars is about
also it kind of spoils the special
guests that you have coming up later in
the episode when you announce them in
the opening credits
however the most unforgivable element of
this is that they
dogged my boy kenny baker r2d2
as r2d2 r2d2s himself
there's a person in there the kids need
to know that there's a person in here
too
chewy is heading home to kashyyyk to
celebrate life day with his family
setting up a location that will become
canon in later star wars films
revenge of the sith depicted the battle
of kashyyyk forcing us to spell it with
three wise as in
why are we spelling it this way oh right
the writers of the star wars holiday
special were paid by the letter
life day also came back in the pilot
episode of the mandalorian that is why
this is required viewing
i was hoping to be free for uh life day
dave filoni needs us all to have the
same insane fandom that he has get on
the bus
drink the kool-aid oh yeah spelled with
three wise we get our next wtf moment
when we meet the chewbacca family
[Music]
why do they all sound the same the
important thing is they're playing
with toys both itchy and lumpy are
playing with x-wing toys
and they seem to be having a great time
i want to play with an x-wing toy
consume can we talk about how their
names are itchy and lumpy
and now i understand that chewie is an
abbreviation of chewbacca
but that would mean that their names are
like lumpaka and
ichbaka i'm gonna guess their nicknames
because otherwise star wars wtf and this
time i mean what the [ __ ]
we're not going to sugarcoat it for you
kids even though this is a holiday
special we're going to get raw
new rock stars after dawn nr stands for
not raided in this episode it's rated
and we will be flagged we stay with
chewbacca son
lumpy for wtf moment number three which
is a bat [ __ ]
cirque du soleil fever dream evidently
lumpy can summon a janky tumbling troop
from what i can only assume is their
permanent prison in hell
simply by pushing a button on a prop
that is clearly a tape recorder
who out there was watching this saying i
hope they don't do cool star wars [ __ ]
instead i hope they focus on a poorly
choreographed holographic tumbling
routine
really this whole segment seems to
answer the question how much cocaine is
too much cocaine we finally get some
luke skywalker action with wtf moment
number four now remember
eric voss gives you easter eggs i give
you cow patties
moments that make you go god i wish i
had never seen this
luke is here to save the day by
problematically telling chewbacca's wife
mala that she needs to smile
come on let's see a little smile
wow a curveball from the chosen luke
basically suggested chewbacca isn't
gonna
want to come home and spend life day
with his shrewish
standoffish wife i think that's the
conflict in the star wars holiday
special
han and chewie are late for a family
party i guess
it's really hard to be sure though
because we are forced to watch four
minutes of amateur tumbling in between
scenes wtf moment has got to be art
carny art carney is a comedy legend and
this scene
actually feels kind of star wars-y
because it features a good guy
tricking a bad guy ultimately though
it's just a transaction scene designed
to
introduce new products that they could
sell to consumers
speaking of which hand sanitizer is
still a super important and in demand
product we're lucky to have some friends
who run a small business that makes hand
sanitizer among other things and they've
been keeping us in stock we
struck a deal with them to distribute
their hand sanitizer which is a great
way to get a product so many people want
and need right now
while also supporting small businesses
including ours
sanitize and chill combines
hospital-grade ethanol-based hand
sanitizer with
cbd we've been heavily involved in
creating the formulation because we
didn't want to get behind any product
that wasn't going to be effective at
killing viruses
we've actually had other medical
professionals weigh in and we were able
to meet the highest levels of guidelines
there's no thc in this stuff so you're
not going to get high
but your hands will get clean every
bottle has 100 milligrams of cbd and the
alcohol content of the sanitizer is
above the 60
the cdc recommends for inactivating
viruses similar to copper 19. this stuff
has 70
ethanol so it is stronger than purely
sanitize
and chill so if you're looking for hand
sanitizer and you want to help new rock
stars act now and grab yourself a bottle
or a 5 or a 10 pack use a link in the
video's description and use the discount
code
nr10 for 10 off your order at
sanitizeandchill.com
click the link in the description to
find out more art carney isn't the only
tv legend to show up in the star wars
holiday special harvey korman comes in
and delivers three characters that are
just bonkers crazy
i can only imagine that the writers
conceived of a spin-off star wars
variety show set in the universe
starring people like carney corman and
a guest star we're gonna get to later i
don't know so the writing staff of this
special is actually made up of late
night tv writers and writers who write
for award shows like bruce valanche
and it makes sense because the story is
basically told in vignettes some
funnier than others to be honest the
problem is none of it really makes sense
and none of it feels really authentic to
star wars harvey corman for his part is
actually pretty hilarious but why am i
watching
him as an alien named gormanda instead
of luke leia han
i told you art carney was coming back
and i am so
sorry to share this scene with you i
don't know why he thinks that in the
midst of an imperial search of
chewbacca's home
itchy chewbacca's father needs to watch
a vr porn but
he does and i don't think i'm reading
into this too much
this is definitely supposed to be sexual
why is this happening when i watched
this special to do the breakdown i
turned this down so that my mom couldn't
hear me watching it i'm a man
in my 30s i've kissed a girl before with
a lot of detective tests determined that
was a lie
i get it diane carroll is beautiful but
isn't there a more nuanced way to keep
horny adult attention on this special
without a five-minute
cyber sex video of all of the celebrity
vignettes the one that makes the most
sense
is jefferson starship showing up in
another virtual reality
segment in real life they were pretty
trippy spaced out band that definitely
seems like they would be at home sharing
a double bill with the cantina band
plus you know they were gonna go and try
and make a record
soundtrack of this special and sell a
million copies
even though this flopped it did pave the
way for the star wars holiday album
christmas in the stars which
i kid you not featured a duet between
r2d2
and bon jovi
all right let's talk about the cartoon
this is the first segment where wtf
actually stands for
wow this is fun this cartoon has lots of
great stuff
boba fett is introduced into the star
wars universe and he's
already being a bastard we get snarky
droids and harrison ford just
basically refusing to participate what
happened
my guess is they brought in an
impersonator probably mark hamill
this was the most fun part of the
special for me as a first-time viewer to
be honest
again even this cartoon felt like it was
obviously a potential spin-off for
future animated projects but i just
don't see animation being a huge part of
star wars moving forward
just kidding at least this was fun star
wars content not just cringy
merchandising opportunities so
thumbs up for the cartoon okay saving
the best wtf
for last in this truly way too
long segment starring b arthur harvey
corman
and every possible alien costume they
had in the warehouse i mean
we got everybody including i think a
werewolf it starts as a comedy sketch
that isn't really that funny
at all aside from harvey korman drinking
through the top of his head
and it ends with b arthur appeasing this
wretched hive with
a free round of drinks after they
threatened to kill her ooh
and a song called good night but not
goodbye
goodnight but not goodbye which at this
point in the special it probably should
have been
again this song is sung as a reward for
all of the bad aliens
not murdering her there is definitely
something funny about her being charmed
by the clientele doing the bare minimum
and just like that one brisk hour and 37
minutes later the star wars holiday
special comes to an
end thank the maker chewbacca was
reunited with his family which i guess
was the point look i love star wars
harrison ford is my favorite actor of
all time but i can't imagine if i was a
kid in 1978
after watching this it really seems like
they hired a bunch of writers who had
never seen or heard of star wars and
tasked them with selling a bunch of toys
and records
i guess little kids might like itchy and
lumpy
the same way that little kids like jar
jar so what is the legacy of this
special i mean much like the fantastic
four video we discussed last time this
is really meant to be forgotten it's a
weird misstep in the galaxy far
far away i will say it's essential
viewing for any star wars fan because if
you don't love star wars at its holiday
special you don't deserve star wars at
its empire strikes back
so give it a watch and let me know what
you think also as always hit me with
suggestions for other long forgotten
terrible properties that you'd like to
see me cover for future bootleg
breakdown
shoot me a comment on the discord by
becoming a patron at patreon.com
newrockstars comment down below follow
me on instagram and twitter at tommybach
told
follow new rockstars and subscribe for
more bootleg breakdowns
may the force be with you
[Music]
you